anybody who you still want to collab
with i also just read is this true that
you and zendaya and kailani were almost
in a band together would you collab with
them now or is there anything
else you want to collab with that would
be crazy yeah me and kelani were in a
group and
and zendaya was around at the time and
she was gonna be at the group but uh
yeah who knows who knows i mean they're
really powerful dope women
and we all came up from the bay area so
maybe we gotta do something from from
the bay who knows
okay anybody who's on your list to work
with next then oh man
i mean it's tons of artists and stevie
wonder is number one i gotta work with
stevie wonder
but i mean there's there's so many dope
r b artists that i want to work with
and khalid was on that list and i and i
did that and migos
was on that list so we're just we're
just crossing them off one at a time
we can't wait to watch you what can we
expect describe
what this show is going to be like i
cannot give away too much all i can say
is it's going to be a lot of
energy and it's going to be kind of
musical at the same time and of course
me collaborating with dj khaled and
amigos it's something you've never seen
before and um
i think it's gonna be one of the first
times that you've seen you know
this many artists on on stage together
so i'm really excited
i mean an incredible i can't even call
it a trio because yeah
it's a group of you yeah what was it
like to get that
call to collab because dj khaled is also
known for like he gets the biggest
people
he has the coolest collaborations
absolutely yeah so
i mean i was in miami and he was like
hey
come to my house and he had the chef
going it was uh
the hospitality was crazy so we go to
his studio and he plays a bit of the
record and it wasn't even completed yet
um but he played a bit of it and i was
like nah this is this is one of those
ones and
and when he knows he got one like he he
really got one
so i i totally trusted him and when i
heard the record i was i was blown away
so
yeah here we are you know i'm at the
billboard awards performing it i'm
really excited
oh he's a hit maker but wait now i have
to know what's on the menu at dj
khaled's house
we had some i don't even know how to
describe it he i don't know the chef
just does a mixture of things but uh i
think he had
like an asian food that night it was
really really good he's over the top in
every way
in every way everything's a movie
um so it has been just a crazy time for
you non-stop award after award
where do you keep all these awards i'm
actually trying to find a
more shelf space because i'm running out
of space which is a great problem to
have
but um as of now my grammys are on the
shelf
and my oscars on my kitchen counter so
we're gonna
we're gonna build build some the
situation uh soon so that
the oscars the oscars next to the
blender and and the keurig what do you
mean it's on a kitchen counter
yeah yeah it's it's safe you know and i
can see it every day so it's almost like
motivation you know oh i love that okay
cool
so yeah what do you think i mean you're
gonna have billboard awards you're gonna
have everything do we need a room what's
your dream for
a place for all these statues a room
that that's a lot i don't know i gotta
put it somewhere where everybody can see
it when they come to my house so
i'll figure out where that is and i'll
make sure i show you a picture when it's
done okay you'll be the first to see it
well thank you i mean but i love that
you are
feeling that sense of accomplishment
because you deserve it i mean
you're 23 right and it's 23 halfway to
it being an egot
are are you gonna hit up broadway
anytime to get that tony would you could
we ever see you on stage
i just might you know i have some some
ambitions too
i i think i think you might see me me
doing that but thank you
i'm trying to celebrate it as much as i
can and take it all in but i'm also one
of those people who's like on to the
next thing i'm like all right
let's get this oscar you know let's get
this emmy let's get this tony and
and you know take it to the moon okay
this sounds like you've actually thought
about it a little bit what could we see
you doing writing a musical
doing something on stage what i think
you could see all of it you know i'm big
i
i i want to score films i want to write
a musical
i want to act in a musical so you could
see it
in many different ways so we'll see um
do you have any pre-show
rituals that you do before something
like performing at billboard
um one of the biggest things is like
just getting in a vibe like all
light like a candle i'm with my team and
and of course we pray
but i also just kind of sit in silence
and get myself hyped and then the energy
comes as i'm like walking to the stage
and that's
usually what it is and that's that's
kind of me i'll relax
and then turn it up